MOBIUS
I'm Agent Mobius, by the way.
LOKI
How long have you been here?
MOBIUS
I don't know, it's hard to say.
You know, time passes
differently here in the TVA.
LOKI
What does that mean?
MOBIUS
You'll catch up.
OWEN WILSON
This is the first time for me
in the Marvel Universe.
They first spoke to me about Iron Man,
and Captain America, and even Hulk.
I was like,
"Well, you know, I don't know."
I'm just kidding.
MOBIUS
I need your unique Loki perspective.
OWEN WILSON
Tom would take us through the world
and the different movies.
KATE HERRON
It was amazing because he just had
all this information in his head.
OWEN WILSON
We called them the Loki lectures.
[Laughing]
I ended up just sort of, writing
down some of the stuff he said,
and I think that it even
worked its way, sometimes, into dialogue.
TOM HIDDLESTON
Owen's full of enthusiasm
and passion and excitement.
OWEN WILSON
I really like the whole look.
The sets and the costumes,
you know, let that do the heavy lifting.
[Laughing]